sitting here to my right the legendary
broadcaster Al Michaels good to see you
sir so I'm preparing for my 40-yard dash
and what is that what does that look
like for you al it looks like I'll be on
like a scooter you know for me I'm just
well you know what what can you do the
40 in these days what are you gonna go
out that would require me to know that
off the top of my head because I've
trained for it right you know the best
time to this point is why 5.94 mmm in a
suit on a tie tie a few years ago after
I damn near ripped the hamstring off the
bone decided to get out of dress shoes
and actually wear actual real running
shoes hood and so I'm gonna be doing
that on Monday we do that on Monday you
know what time today well that will be
airing at 1:30 p.m. Eastern Time so
around 10:30 in the morning I'll be
tuned in will you be are you gonna be on
the course or what are you gonna be me
no no no Mike my course is closed until
right so I need any invite from any of
my buddies who just seem to disappear
Hiram's comes the time for reciprocation
that's it so yeah so I'm getting ready
to run that over the weekend you know
procedure Children's Research on you
know great raise as much money as
possible and so are you gonna be tuning
in the combine every now and then I get
an email or a text from you that you're
locked
I wouldn't say locked I can't watch the
whole thing I mean I'm just talking
about here right but I mean how many
hours of coverage we should be raising
money for charity it should be a
telethon that's how many hours that were
on the air who I should sing I should
sing at the end you know to celebrate
the the the amassing of war chests for
some charity um but I mean so what at
your level of interest in seeing some of
these kids that you're gonna be calling
oh sure I want to see you know the top
guys obviously the guys that I know are
gonna be drafted in the first or second
round just to see what's going on and
you know I'll come check it out a good
part of the day just you know people say
you know how much preparation is there
to do Sunday Night Football and I tell
them it's it's all year long and Cris
Collinsworth obviously the
same way Chris running pro Football
Focus oh yes so we never fall away from
it so it's a year-round endeavor for us
to to get prepped for for you know
whatever a number of games we're doing
it's like nineteen next year then we we
we always feel it at the NFL Network
putting it on the air that the three
weeks weekends of no football is
people's appetites are ready for any
conversation or anything that remotely
looks like football since obviously
Super Bowl 52 left us all on some sort
of high just watching that game where
does that game rank in terms of the
Super Bowls that you've called well it's
a it's very interesting because the last
four that I've been a part of all at at
NBC after the first six in a minute ABC
all four have been fantastic you
Pittsburgh Arizona with in Super Bowl 43
the diamond Tampa was fantastic James
Harrison with that hundred yard the
interception return Santoni Houmas makes
the catch
Kurt Warner's in the game for Arizona
Larry Fitzgerald had they won the game I
mean that would have been as good a
postseason as anybody's ever had and
then we did Giants and Patriots this
round too in 2011 which ironically ended
the same way that this game ended with
Brady throwing a pass into the end zone
for Gronkowski incomplete Giants when
the game for Tom Coughlin and Eli
Manning and then we did Seattle against
New England three years ago the Malcom
Butler interception and this one so Fred
Goodell Leandre sack often and our gang
walked out of the stadium in Minneapolis
and said boy did we were living with
some rabbit's feet here we did do four
in a row
so I know it's it's hard for me to rank
him I mean I always thought nothing
could be Pittsburgh Arizona then you
look at this game the great thing about
this game I thought was that it was
compelling from start to finish how many
games in the NFL are great for 60
minutes and people would say you know
last year with New England coming from
behind down 28 to 3 that really wasn't a
very good game for 43 minutes the last
17 minutes were pretty terrific plus
overtime so but this game
from start to finish you know games have
an ebb and a flow and this one just had
60 minutes of flow and and trick plays
oh that we'll be talking about for quite
some time sure that Philly special I
thought when that timeout was called we
had Doug Peterson on the air last week
and he said that he was intending to go
for it that he just wanted to call
timeout cuz clock was winding down he
had no thoughts about kicking that field
goal right uh what was going through
your mind with Chris is that timeout hit
and then the play that unfolded right
well you know this has been
Doug's MO most of the season most of
last season as well in his two years I
mean he goes through a lot on forth them
I thought it was you know a very gutsy
call you know it's one of those things
where if it works Wow if it doesn't work
you know you're a bum and a [ __ ] but
this is this is what football is all
about everybody's sitting there going
wow isn't that fantastic but if they
hadn't made it you know he was trying to
do their so but that's I think
Philadelphia was a fascinating team to
watch this year I mean the story was
great we all know about you know once
going down folds taken over you know
Doug in his second year with them
Philadelphia having never won the
Superbowl I mean the the stories were
all compelling so when you look at the
game itself and the backstories involved
in that game I mean that's as good as it
gets
how Michaels here in the Rich Eisen show
so interestingly enough you were at the
mic for Malcom Butler's emergence
correct and then you were at the mic for
his disappearance correct one end to the
other throughout the week did what were
you and Chris seeing that that might
have indicated what was going on with
New England well we have access to
practice and the day we went to practice
he practiced every fight so nobody had
any idea about this I do know you know
Devin McCourty has been quoted recently
as saying everybody knew about it I'm
thinking we'll wait a minute how did
everybody know about this if he's
practicing every play and the only thing
I would say in retrospect first of all
we don't know really what happened to
get sooner or
it had to be something there there has
to be something there correct and he's
you know we had a shot of him crying
during the national anthem so he knew at
that point I guess that he wasn't gonna
play and then the game evolves the way
it does and they're getting shredded in
the secondary so why does he not come in
and the only question I would have is in
addition to obviously trying to find out
what really happened if he's not gonna
play why wasn't he deactivated why
wouldn't you if he's not gonna play put
him over here
he's inactive and then somebody else
comes up that's the only thing that
surprised me and I I've talked to a
couple of NFL coaches as well and that
surprised them as well in terms of you
know if you're not gonna play the guy
deactivate him and it's amazing because
Malcolm Butler's interception took away
what would have been the major takeaway
in conversation about that Super Bowl
was Bella checks use of timeouts that
that we would all been wondering why did
he call timeout why did he let the clock
wind down for what was an eventual
game-winning touchdown so we removed
that now Butler's disappearance has led
us to wonder what was Belichick thinking
it has shaken the in bill We Trust
foundation to its core yeah in New
England I think there was a headline in
one of the Boston papers that said a
couple of days later hey Bill do your
job
let us know what happened so this is
again another reason why we love the NFL
why we love sports because we there's a
lot of mystery out there mm-hmm
I guess the one thing that won't be
mysterious is that Malcolm Butler will
be playing for some other team next year
exactly we have to think and knowing
Robert Kraft as well as you do and half
what do you think is gonna happen with
him and Brady and Belichick or do you
know if that's even happened I know he
was out here sitting underneath the hoop
for the all-star game the NBA all-star
game last week Robert Kraft what can you
well I haven't had a conversation with
him about that but I mean I would have
to think I mean Brady's gonna keep on
going 40 years old he's the MVP of the
league Tom loves it loves playing I
assume Belichick is gonna be back yeah
yeah it's just you have to assume that
mm-hmm
I mean they kept McDaniels obviously we
know what
what took place Patricia goes to Detroit
and all of that but I'd be surprised if
you didn't see the B&B boys back for at
least next year I mean for Tom
I mean it's fascinating you you watch
him he's 40 years old he's the MVP the
league is another spectacular season
comes close to winning another Super
Bowl is played in what seven them now I
think if you if you if you walk away the
guys who walk away
I think the net for the following year
has been very tough for them you know
could I have played a little bit longer
and I know some quarterbacks you know
through recent times who said we don't
maybe I retired a little too early right
I think Tom wants to play out the string
but I I think Tom Tom would have to play
at the level he's playing at to continue
on I mean if all of a sudden he you know
became half of what he was I think he
would walk away then but not right now
he's the league MVP and what is the
scuttlebutt already if you and the rest
of the Sunday Night Football crew I've
even put a mind to this about who you
think is gonna be the first team out for
Philadelphia your first called well
they've got a pretty good scheduling I
sure do yeah Minnesota goes in there so
you get the the likelihood of maybe that
game being the opening game on Thursday
night they remember they're in a
division with Dallas they were in
Washington and New York so anytime you
have the NFC East you know that's pretty
good so that that's half your schedule I
forgot who the who else they have I
maybe they've got a Carolina right
they've got Carolina I've got Houston if
you really want to mix it up and deshaun
Watson I don't know if that that's
something to but I know that you know
again latest word out of the New York
Times is that the commissioners gonna
get set to find Jerry Jones and then the
reports are it's not really a fine
they're gonna make him pay the legal
fees for suing the competition committee
or the compensation committee or the
threatening or all that you don't think
they'd put Jerry Jones in that building
so he would personally witness the
Philadelphia Eagles raising a banner I
mean that would be somebody could happen
we love having the Cowboys on Sunday
night and the reason is you know people
they they engender emotion people either
love them or hate them but
you have feelings about the Cowboys and
I say we'd love to have mom because the
ratings are great I mean there are
certain teams we put on and you know
gonna do a big number mmm the Dallas
Cowboys are one of them so you use them
there or do you wait gonna down the line
mean there are so many ways to you know
fold down listen to the Sunday night
schedule that we have a lot of options
there so I Kings to Vikings no not three
minutes Vikings yeah the Vikings
certainly if Kirk Cousins is the
quarterback there that would be Kirk's
first game back in the NFC either yep
run back the NFC Championship game see
if it's a different result could be
that's something so again you're here
all hour long and last week was the
Miracle on Ice speaking of engendering
emotion 38 years frightening removed so
when we come back Mike Eruzione is gonna
choke ah
well stroll down memory lane of it I'm
told he's fresh off a golf course does
that surprise you or fresh on one radar
with the cell phone Americus guess Mike
Eruzione we will find out we will find
out Mike Eruzione will join us and then
where will hit on some other topics
since this is one of the first Olympics
you've watched right it's like the rest
of us in a while
Mike Eruzione when we come back with Al
Michaels right here on this edition of
the Rich Eisen show welcome back to the
Rich Eisen show last Thursday
it was the 38th anniversary of the
Miracle on Ice which it's called for
many different reasons
part of it is because of the call that
you made al michaels on that night do
you know believe in miracles nothing
will top that in terms of my career I've
been lucky enough to do a lot of great
events but nothing could eclipse that I
mean when you consider everything it
took place around that game what it
meant to the country you didn't have to
like hockey to exalt over what had taken
place that night so that was that's a
stand alone
for three final score over the Soviet
Union and the man who lit the lamp to
give Team USA the lead that night at the
ten-minute mark exactly of the third
period is kind enough to call in without
Michaels right here in studio the
captain of the 1980 Winter Olympics US
men's now
hockey team Mike Eruzione how are you
Mike I'm great how you doing buddy I'm
fantastic
he calls me alfalfa a name Bob Uecker
gave me many many years ago and the
other one is harsh never we you know we
always loved the fact that Keith Jackson
the link came to action the great Keith
Jackson used to call everybody he's a
horse and then he called you greener
when you green was at Pittsburgh and a
great dinner great defensive Andy called
he said he's a horse and a half so Mike
and I believe cost each other for 38
years now when was the last when was the
first time Mike that you met al do you
recall that in Lake Placid mm-hmm and
then I ended up having the pleasure
working with Alan Kensi Olympic Games
you know after when I was when I was a
commentator so um and then over the
years we've run into each other here in
the air and golf tournaments dinners and
like I said he's a special friend and we
consider him you know part of our team
whenever you know our team has a reunion
and we haven't had many but we always
try to ask y'all to come because he's
like an extended member of our family
well I feel like the mascot I'm like the
San Diego chicken with you guys I mean
you you guys wrote the script I just
happened to have you know be the coda on
at the end of the game but what you guys
did I means 38 years later people just
still love to talk about it and you know
the thing riches that Mike you know goes
around the country and we played that
tape and then Mike gets up there and the
place just goes crazy crazy it's really
been funny out you know especially know
the last Olympic Games obviously the
phone rings off the hook everybody wants
to talk about it everybody wants to
compare was this year's team like the
1980 team and then I got an article the
other day the curling team that won the
gold medal it was called Miracle on Ice
right girl
yeah merit curl that's right miracle I
think they said the article was yes and
you know you try to noting that this
will never happen again and it's not
about patting ourselves on the back it's
just the whole criteria the scenario the
Russians Russia's you know 37 countries
not one and the amateur versus the pros
and
it'll be an event that you just kind of
leave it alone and let it sit by itself
now you you have to in and you know
inside the game itself Mike you know
when you think about the fact that
people always forget that you guys were
able to overcome three deficits it was
one nothing it was two one it was three
two Soviets you get the the game-winning
goal as it turned out the tiebreaking
gold the ten minute mark but the other
thing is you well know so much of the
game was played in the United States and
people forget the Soviets had thirty
nine shots on goal and the United States
at sixteen right you know it's funny I
saw the game the other day out for the
second time since 1980 I'm in the
process of possibly writing a book and
the author a co-author
wanted me to watch the game with him and
I said you know I really haven't seen it
but it'd be fun to watch and it was
amazing to watch the last ten minutes
though when we took the lead I think
they only had three shots on goal in the
last ten minutes of the game I was
surprised at how well we played once we
once we got the lead and then the other
thing that people don't remember and I
and I and I tell him all the time is we
didn't play just one game you know we
were we were behind against Sweden we
were behind against the Czechs we're
behind against Norway we're behind two
against West Germany right behind
against Finland and still found a way to
come back and win right I think that
just the testament you know we we
weren't lucky it wasn't look we had some
pretty good players oh as it turned out
no question about it and such resolving
such resiliency and you know when you
watch the those last 10 minutes and what
I remember about those last 10 minutes
to things Mike number one I mean all of
a sudden the US team begins to dominate
if the Soviets had really dominated for
the first like 48 50 minutes of the game
and then I remember the Soviets were
skating insanely short shifts they were
it was almost like they were out of
rhythm guys around the ice for 20
seconds then they're wrong and the other
thing that people forget Mike is they
didn't pull the goalie right they didn't
pull them because I thought to myself
and this was long after the game had
ended that they probably never practiced
it they never lost so they were never
down within the last minute of the game
but they never they never pulled the
goalie yeah they never pulled the goalie
and the other thing when I watched the
game was they
three or four icings in the last 10
minutes
they never that was very
uncharacteristic of the Soviets they
never dumped the puck in the zone you
know they always regrouped and went and
attacked and you know again our speed
our conditioning our youth all came to a
head right there in our advantage
yeah you know Mike I think about so many
things I mean when the Russians won the
gold medal the other night and beat me
Germany what the shocking thing to me
was in those years
the Soviets won constantly so they would
win the game in a big deal maybe they'd
congratulate each other and then they'd
get into the line to you know shake the
opponent's hands meanwhile the Russians
the other night they were almost like
you guys were in 1980 and I think I told
you that in Sochi I had the chance to
interview Tretiak who was the goalie who
was pulled into the first period and
Michigan came in to finish the game and
I said to him you know you know Mike
there's that great shot when you guys
are celebrating at the end of that game
and you guys are all over the ice and
you're all falling down and on top of
each other and the great toothless grin
from Jack O'Callahan and there's that
one cutaway shot I think the guy was I
think was Golic off of the Soviet team
and he had his his shin perched on the
stick and he had that look like you know
wow look at that look at what those guys
are doing and I said to Tretiak and
Sochi when I had him in the studio I
should what were you guys thinking he's
you know you guys didn't do that you saw
the American team jumping up and down
falling down on the ISIL he said they
looked like the happiest people in the
world we wish we were them so I mean
here we are 38 years later and you saw a
very different emotion on the part of
the Russian team when they went ahead of
the other day Mike Eruzione here on the
Rich Eisen show along with Al Michaels
live this is great I just like listening
to the two you guys go back and forth
Mike I do have to ask you you said that
it's only the second time you've seen
this game what why have you only watched
it twice Mike I know the outcome yeah
there's one and number two the last
thing I want to be is sitting at home
in a game and one of my buddy shows up
and says Mike let it go so I have two
grandsons right now and I think we'll
probably about three or four years away
from maybe watching it again with them
and let them get a sense of what Papa
did and it's it's funny house you'll get
a kick out of this my grandsons now
skate at the Mike Eruzione Center Wow
three and but they have no idea who my
crew Sione is hey Mike don't forget you
you once told me that maybe you haven't
watched the whole game except you know a
couple of times now but you have watched
the highlight of of your Goldie's
remember you once told me he's you know
you said you know if I go home I'm a
little down I'll put the tape in and he
said the best thing about it is that
every time I shoot the puck goes in what
was the first time when was the first
time after the the game after that those
Olympics Mike that you saw I had I had a
VHS tape sir
and it probably was maybe three years
after the games and unfortunately the
tape that I have only has highlights it
doesn't have the whole game so I found
out like I said when I went with the
co-author that you can go on demand are
on YouTube who watched the whole game in
its entirety so that was the first time
I've ever seen the whole game and you
know I know the game was replayed but
not replayed it was take delay so all my
all my teammates had a chance to watch
the game after we won because they all
went back to the house with our parents
and watch but I was grabbed Jimmy Craig
and I were grabbed by ABC and did a
bunch of interviews and did a thing in
the street with Jim Lampley
so I you know all my teammates got to
see it that night I and I didn't get to
see it then mm-hmm so last one for you
both
Al Michaels Mike Eruzione here together
just a few days after the 38th
anniversary of the Miracle on Ice you
first alamin and then you Mike how do
you think Herb Brooks would take what we
think of this team 38 years later if he
was alive today what it means to
everybody what do you what do you think
he would say about that well the
interesting thing about her
herb was a hockey coach and the rest of
the world existed but he he was so
driven and so focused and he brought
that team to the point where they did
what they did but here it was I'll never
forget a week and a half later Herb
Brooks could have been king of America
at that point I mean he he had to be the
most popular person in the United States
what did he do instead of going around
the country and you know taking all the
accolades and all the rest he went to
Switzerland and he coached a club team I
think in Davos Wow
he was a hockey coach and the other
thing briefly is that when Sports
Illustrated in 1999 took over Madison
Square Garden and did a show they put 12
or 15 12 13 thousand people in the arena
and the u.s. victory in the 80 Olympics
was ranked as the number one moment and
they had me introduced the team the
place went crazy and herb and I are
walking down the stairs and he looked at
me and he said how could they vote that
number one and I said herb how could
they not voted number one don't you
understand what happened right so herb
he was a hockey coach and everything
else was ancillary Mike yeah you know
how I would agree and that a hundred
percent you know I remember he never
when we had some functions he never even
came to the function he just stayed away
he let us enjoy the moment you know he
was the coach but we were the players
and and he let us enjoy every moment and
it's funny the last time we were on the
ice at Madison Square Garden was when we
lost 10 to 3 to the Soviets and now
we're in tuxedos being claimed the
greatest moment the 20s in the 20th
century so herb was very proud of our
team and I think he would have been even
prouder now knowing how special that
moment has has become in the hockey
world how many more kids probably
started playing hockey because of what
we did in 1980 and I've said many times
we might have opened the door but
today's players have knocked the door
down so I think herb would have been
very proud of where USA Hockey is at and
it started I think really in 1980 in
fact you know just a button up what you
said when I enter any a can we did that
interview
but you guys looking like the happiest
guys in the world he said American
hockey hoes that team the the what
they're what they're doing right now
they they opened up the door
they created you know what hockey is in
this country right now a lot bigger than
it was in 1980 and it's all thanks to
that team in 1980 and thanks to you Mike
I really appreciate you taking the time
to join out here in studio and your
first foray here on the show hope it's
not your last I appreciate it thank you
and now Linda and I'm on the 15th hole
right now so I'll talk to you and hi to
Donna who over here was called Donna you
know he's married to Donna but it's
always like da wna and Mike again I just
want to speak just real quick I'm
speaking on behalf of the speaking on
behalf of the 11 year old and watch that
thank you thank you you're more than
welcome thanks you better be bad I'm
like I get emotional I'll you know I get
emotional 38 years later I just I almost
just broke down right there people say
to me when they look at that tape they
start to cry this is even people who
weren't alive at that point for some
reason I don't know what it is it was
just the way the game ended and you know
to wash that unbridled celebration and
reaction from the team was fantastic now
it was awesome back with more with Al
Michaels in 60 seconds here in the Rich
Eisen show
I gotta turn the man who called that out
Michaels what do you think when you hear
that you hear your your voice from 38
years ago well it's almost third person
you know I know it's me obviously but I
watch it and I'm kind of like removed
from it I mean I'm in the audience you
know what's gonna happen you seen it you
know dozens hundreds of times or
whatever it is for me over the years but
still it's it's such an exciting moment
that I kind of get caught up and I
understand how people get caught up in
it as well because even if you know the
backstory you know what what that game
meant and then you see it it's still
special you know what's gonna happen
it's like I guess maybe like watching a
great scene from a movie that you love
you can't watch you can't watch it
enough you get the same emotion but you
know for me it's exciting yeah I mean
I've seen the movie miracle right where
Kurt Russell plays her Brooks and I
remember first time I thought I've seen
it so many times he I'm on the edge of
my seat what's happening here because I
know what's going on here and it's a
movie gavin o'connor directed he did a
great job and i I worked you know behind
the scenes with him and put down some
new tracks some voice tracks to kind of
connect the dots for them right
with the scenes that they shot but he
did a terrific job look there's a little
literary license taken in every movie
where you just recreating sir what took
place but I thought he really stayed
true to the story and he had to fight
his way through because when you do in a
movie I mean he wants to stay true to
what really happened and he got all the
you know jablow knees in the executive
suite going we want to make this a urban
paddy Brooks love story no not not
really so I gave Gavin a lot of credit
for how that movie turned and they use
your original call in the film and what
the original write the last 30 seconds
30 seconds oh yeah there was a sound guy
who'd wanted a bunch of Academy Awards
who wanted me to redo that lease it's
kind of a dirty track you know it's like
all these years later I said no way yeah
I mean I had if there's a word in
between knowing way but
it's funny Chris Brockman uh you know it
again it was just great listening to you
and Mike Eruzione gonna go back and
forth like two old friends who were part
of only you know the greatest moment
maybe in the history of sports just
reminiscing it and you know we go to
break and we're all quiet then you say
why are the reason why people crying
Chris Brockport crying because they had
to look at your honey hideous blue
sweater yeah where's that sweater now
well that's a good question
it used to be in the closet but I think
somebody might have come in there and
took it somewhere so now is this like
Roone Arledge issued is that what it was
like we all got together this works and
I swear we're gonna put him in a blue
sweater and well I think the the budget
for wardrobe in those years was like 18
bucks and then get one for Dryden too
and I some shirt with a big collar
coming out of it yeah and the fro you
had that yeah yeah at the Afro people
have a bad hair day I've had a bad place
they had here a life stop it
well come on man you're looking great
out and look at me did you and so what
was it like for you said being us you
felt like you're being a spectator
listening to your voice 38 years ago
what was it like watching in Olympics
when was the last time you watched in LA
well I did the last I did Vancouver
London Sochi and Rio so that's four in a
row right so it's been since 2008 okay I
see alright since I did a whole bunch of
it I had at ABC and then the last four
at NBC it was interesting you know being
at home and you know you kind of
understand what's happening behind the
scenes and all of that but you know I'm
very proud of you know my network's
coverage of it you know we live in this
world of everybody criticizes so much
and people say to me yeah you know I
needed more stories or fewer stories or
what everybody's got their own take on
it but I mean to me the Olympics are
very special and what in the
world is wrong with the fact that the
world comes together for two weeks and
there's such snark out there about our
you know now we go back to the real
world well fine but how about you know
two weeks two and a half weeks where
people from almost every country on
earth get together and have a good time
yeah and part of the criticism if you
will I've found interestingly enough
just I guess bring this whole thing full
circle is that there were not NHL
players out there on the ice and now
we're used to it it was it was as if the
nineteen eighty type hockey tournament
was recreated this time around and it
missed a little bit of the possess that
we fixed well I think since the NA show
became a part of the Winter Olympics and
that was going back to the late 90s the
quality of play was fantastic I mean I
thought the quality of play in Vancouver
was off the charts no it's when Sidney
Crosby scored the the game-winning goal
in overtime beats the US and so many so
many of the the Russians now Soviets in
the country you know broke up and now
they're there Russia so many of those
guys play in the National Hockey League
so you know they had they had some
pretty good plan we dot suits been a you
know around for a long long time
Ovechkin wasn't there mm-hm so you kind
of missed that quality of play but I
thought it was it was compelling I
watched a lot of the Olympic hockey and
it was pretty good and women winning on
the 38th anniversary of The Miracle on
38th anniversary right great game
tremendous gains great overtime shootout
what do you think of that real quick
the shootout to the side of gold medal
right that's the one time they should
probably play the Stanley Cup you know
play let it go else are we going I
thought it's interesting they lead the
men only had a ten minute overtime but
the women had a twenty minute overtime
on it's the women are tougher to be
honest there when we come back we are
going to indoctrinate Al Michaels in his
final segment here on this show of this
hour indoctrinate Alan to start bench
cut
I'll give you an idea again start bench
cut you have to start one you have to
bench when you have to cut one and first
up is gonna be a steak start bench cut
I'm hungry already okay
that's Al Michaels one more segment with
him on this hour and then shemar Moore
of Swat then your phone calls eight four
four two oh four rich i'll Michael's one
last segment here on always appreciate
you coming aids great we love having
beautiful thanks now so we have we
started a game was it's about a few
weeks ago a couple months ago couple
months ago I think would you say it's
captured the nation yeah and then defy
anybody to deny it exactly thank you
star they're not making any movies at a
start bench cut not yet not yet not yet
so any rate so you al michaels we're
gonna give you a choice of three okay
and you must start one okay you're Tom
Brady if you will you must bench one all
right without Michaels first one up for
our Michaels and start bench cut do you
have any music Mike tell Tufo please
thank you
cuts of steak Rimma rib eye filet mignon
New York Strip rib eye filet mignon New
York Strip you must start one bench one
hand cut one now Michaels New York Strip
is the Hall of Fame's is you know on the
bench mmm ribeye is great but the
problem is it's so fatty hmm you know
you're always watching your weight so I
love ribeye but I gotta cut your cotton
ribbon I'm cutting that's the best first
ballot first ballot yeah yeah they
waived the five-year waiting period to
and it's your medium-rare guy right
meaning we're plus okay we're pro x one
up for our Al Michaels start bench cut
event to call Superbowl World Series
Olympics start venture boy oh yeah well
Superbowl World Series Olympics you
think I gotta hit the Super Bowl as the
starter okay
bench what am I gonna bench here that's
the idea haven't done the World Series
since 1995 so that's
I guess I can't the Olympics you'll
bench the Olympics well yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna put the Olympics on waivers
but I'm gonna I'm gonna bring I'm gonna
bring it back okay oh we got a bonus one
you have oh yeah we got a bonus one all
right already
golf partner start bench cut golf
partner okay Doc Rivers Pete Sampras
Rich Eisen since I played golf with all
of these guys you know probably start
doc I knew that the stock is extremely
competitive pieces a lot of fun to play
with but Pina
Pete he's been through the competitive
realm of his life so he's out there to
have fun and it's rich I'm sorry but you
know I'm cut let's put it this way
neither of us are not fun neither of us
would make the cut we'd be God by Friday
afternoon how's a crowd-pleaser you know
that's exactly what you want to hear
this Alice Tiger back did you find her
back back - is he gonna win the Masters
nope no he's not no come I don't I don't
think a guy can come off feminie back
surgeries and I think it was pretty you
know what he did in Florida last week
was impressive good very impressive too
many good young guys out there right now
you know it's not like he it was in the
past when he was lapping the field there
you go it would take he's an honest man
right thanks for coming in amen I'll
break this any year you want to keep
doing this Miracle on Ice one hour I
live up the freeway like next week
excellent that's great Mall spot you can
see it now see you next week yeah you
bet that's how Michaels here on the Rich
Eisen show Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience